he didn't want to give away anything too
specific right like so he just took one
position right like the late middle game
position or like an opening trap
basically but it was move 18 yeah oh you
saw that too okay
yeah his contents good but so losses
like but king each one is not impressive
no okay I am live someone is asking
who's that in the background this is
going to be a quick stream I'm at a
hotel in Schaumburg Illinois and I'm
playing a tournament this weekend and I
just played round one a few hours ago
the guy in the background is probably
one of the strongest FM's in the world
that's not bad and this is a team
tournament that I'm playing in so I'm
work to on it's on our team
he's board one so I'll get easier games
so I'm gonna analyze the last game I
played I should be able to remember it
minimize everything it was some good
opening I have three d 5b three I wanted
to play like a reverse London I just
wanted to play like Bishop at 5 e 6
minus 6 but then I was scared like he
would double fee and Heather will put
the palm in d3 and it's like a Kings
Indian up a tempo
so I don't know I played nine of six it
should be too
I was seriously debating Bishop f5 mmm
how many times has this been played it's
opening book not working
wait what oh there we go
this should be to push it by five C
masters dad base so it's been played
before
ooh Carlston played this Carlsen lost
agree shook as White was this game if
you okay I'll open the chat let's see
who's here oh but when I open the chat I
don't see any of the old messages so I
have to look here I see tactical wizard
said something is your whole team
analyzing and preparing together we had
food together and we analyzed a little
bit we platelets a little bit but
nothing too major okay what happened in
this game g3 e6
so is literally just a reverse London
which I guess I could have played this I
go for play on the queenside but beating
Carlsen with black and this sort of
structure not easy and this is like a
Carlsen type position too
94 in a stick who annotated this ouch 1c
to invade and it's not easy to be
Carlsen Bishop take d3 what
oh it's pinned ok grease looks pretty
good so I couldn't play Bishop f5 very
attempted I play D six the idea was I
knew I didn't want to like commit the
LightSquared Bishop and I just wanted to
complete kingside developments and I
thought we might get into the slide
where he plays some c4 move and then I
would play it like this kind of
interesting a5 a4 line so it had some
potential what are people saying
tactical wizard says rook takes e8 seems
really odd right there in the Carlson
game row take c8 I just giving up the C
file I think the problem is if white
tries to reinforce the roof a3 would
hang so like take take take on 83
like white doesn't want to surrender the
the C file probably had to anyway let's
look at what happened in my game I play
d6 he played g3 and we were both taking
time like for the first he was even
taking time before playing b3 he took
like 2 or 3 minutes and I took time to
play b6 but then we play the next few
moves pretty quickly Bishop e7 Bishop g2
[Music]
castle castle and then I play c5 and I
was hoping that
we would go into some Benoni structure
is a stream unit it better not be muted
I don't think the Internet's very good
here though so there might be lag with
the video or audio it went mute as soon
as he read my message what's going on oh
yes mm-hmm
I'm gonna keep talking if it's bad it's
gonna be a quick stream so I'll fix it
in the future hopefully it's not too
unwatchable so when I played c5 I was
sort of expecting sons he for d4 III and
then knight c6 the quality is down sorry
about that
take take Ricky one and I think yeah
this is just a mainline like 98 somehow
he transposed from a weird move order
and d3 and then f6 I think so that's
what I was expecting but he played kind
of a strange move yes which is the
second most popular move III I was
actually thinking maybe you could play
d4 right away because I don't
necessarily want to take because I'm the
the double feeling care though it can be
dangerous if the position opens up I was
actually thinking about playing b5 here
there any games
one game b5 feel like I've had this
position before
after a c4 and take take the transpose
Bishop e7 this is actually bugging me
let me Google um so I play the
tournament over the summer and it was a
very similar line this looks promising
I was back it was already opening maybe
this is a game I know Lee chess isn't or
might not be happy with me if I'm going
away from the websites so what I'll do
is I'll copy the PGN and then bring it
into the study
PGM paste okay so that worked so it was
really similar oh except the bishop
didn't commit to be two but this was an
interesting game like black equalised
pretty easily and then there was about
tension in the center and somehow
somehow I won this game after some
trouble white was better at some points
but then he played really badly like he
forgot my C pawn is strong okay got the
AIDS and then White was losing gold
eagle X is asking are you playing any
standard games today I played a bunch of
standard games yesterday but I'm not
playing any and he games online today
because I'm playing in a standard
tournament currently I have a game
tomorrow morning so I'm just analyzing
my my first round game which is right
here so let's flip the board and let's
continue if you want to see me play
standard games you can watch yesterday's
stream
I played for like two hours and some
rapid tournaments and I think that was
decent quality chess but okay so what
happened this game you played III which
I thought was sort of a waste of time
but maybe he's just preparing c4
so I played knight c6 and then he played
t4 so he was kind of mixing up plans but
I thought if he plays d4 then the pawn
on e3 is not really that useful because
if I take he's probably going to take
with Knight
so none that was debating here between
b5 and b6 and it's a question of how to
improve the bishop
I played b6 aiming for a bishop a6 I
guess and that's essentially what
happened to the plenty here he played c4
92 first yeah he played c4 they should a
six so it's somewhat symmetrical like
pawn structure is almost identically
symmetrical the accession of the pollen
g3 and the bishops are are slightly
slightly different squares for each side
so it's the type of position there's a
lot of tension and like a lot of moments
for the next several moves are critical
because it comes down to like who
releases attention first and what side
it favors normally when there's pawns on
d4 c4 d5 c5 it makes sense for one side
to make a capture but in this case or in
this game we left the tension for a
little bit
aka cuttlefish and I still dint know aka
cuttlefish you're not banned I gave you
a time outs
I think a couple of days ago because you
were being a little bit spammy but maybe
I just didn't realize that context I
don't know so welcome back we're gonna
keep going in this game Knight bTW to
rook c8 rook c1 yeah so I played rook c8
I think I played it relatively quickly
then he played rook c1 relatively
quickly I think he just forgot that I
could play Knight d4 here and I'm like
why it's already under some pressure and
when I played night before I thought it
was like really strong but maybe it
wasn't like super strong because I am
threatening 93 and I take a 2 but he
played a good movie played 95
and then the problem was that if I take
on a - of course is what I wanted to do
you could play Roque one might be for
Bishop c3 and I think white wins back
while falling with a good position
I think Bishop b7 take take buckets of
Bishop parent but I wasn't really sure
about this
hello to the guy whose name I can't
pronounce he ago Andrew of eighteen I
know I am getting challenges but I'm not
going to accept them this is this is
just going to be a very quick stream to
go over a game when I finish the
tournament which is on Sunday I'll be
playing more games starting probably on
Monday so bear with me let's go back I
wanted to take on a two but I couldn't
really find an advantage there and 95
defended this night d3 threat so I
played Knight d7 which I think was
reasonable trying to like remove the
night from e5 so I could access d3 I was
expecting Knight d3 but he took which I
think favored me take and then he played
Knight f3 so maybe it's somewhat similar
played Bishop 806 and it looked really
good for luck like it looked like
there's a lot of pins everywhere a 2 is
still potentially hanging but I didn't
see any way to like win anything after
gone did he play here Bishop f6 a3i
retreat and then yeah then he takes
relieving the tension and I can't take
on that one because he takes my knight
attacking my queen so I take he played
rook e1
and then I played rookie eights and I
thought its solo type of position I
could go for some advantage and try not
play him the problem in many situations
this Bishop is just a bad piece on b2
and I'm preventing any 95 move also
restricting an e4 break so I felt pretty
comfortable here
he played rook c2 trying to take as a
bishops defended so I played c4 he took
I took and then he just completely
collapsed I mean black has a very simple
threat Bishop to b3 so I was expecting
[Music]
what was I expecting 92 Bishop e6 rook
c3 Bishop f5
I thought Bach has some slight edge
hello breathing how's it going a long
time no talk just kidding yeah I was
expecting something like this I was
actually calculating cuz he spent a long
time in this moment and like when he was
thinking I was calculating the sign I
was imagining or maybe I was just
daydreaming that's some day like this
would happen Queen at 3 and I have this
night ez 7 move and then let's say he
plays rooks he warned us at this
position maybe it's this position I was
dreaming of somehow trapping his Queen
like Bishop g4 Queen f4 oh but I don't
have g5 because he has Queen take f6
that's annoying I don't think this works
either Knight g6 take take oh wait I
could take the Queen wait is a screen
just trapped
I mean this is some far-off line but I
thought it maybe has some some venom and
white has to be a little bit careful so
none of that happened
she didn't play 92 he played a really
bad move kind of an inexplicable move he
played 95 clearly just missing Bishop b3
that's after this should take me five
pawn to e5 I was actually wondering like
if he just forgot I could take on e5
again because that also looked playable
but of course just Bishop b3 I might as
well I'm gonna go through and put the
whole game in rest of the game was just
a matter of converting but the
conversion was pretty smooth
he played rookie - I took not taking the
rook immediately but just applying
pressure he took on e5 I took on c2 some
things nitrated i play or he played
Queen a1 which is a one sort of try in
the position but very easily met with
with f6 Bishop d4 as an e4 at 3 Bishop
f5 and here I'm kind of forgetting what
happened what did he play and play g4
burned down
Bishop f5 rook T - yeah
rook D - Queen B 5 just going first on
attempted trading Queens so he played
rook oh yeah he played rook b2 and this
was a funny moment hello everyone in the
chat by the way yeah hello Braden hello
camel nice that you guys are interacting
with each other there this was a funny
moment he has one trick where if I play
queen d3 looks like a really like nice
aggressive
you simply plays Bishop f1 and I think
this would be tragic if if it actually
happened because the Queen's trapped so
thankfully I was awake I played Queen C
for threatening Queen c1 you play Queen
e2 wait you play Queen e2 really wait
what happened he didn't play 22 you
played King f2 yeah
King f2 I play Queen c1 going for the
Queen trade knowing that any any end
game without Queens is an easy win so he
played Queen a2 and then I was happy
with the way I I managed to convert I
played rook c4 aiming to potentially
sacrifice on g4
he played g4 and then yeah this position
when I played rook c4 initially I
thought like I could just play rook c2
here and trade but then I realized
there's actually a very strong way to
finish things off
it was just take on on d4 because if he
takes back there's this Queen e1 mates
so this is what happened the game he
took on a5 I take on e3 and here it's
actually forced mates after a simple
series of checks King g3 Queen e5 King
h3 take goes back actually the force
made here it's maybe a little bit tricky
to find when I go back to e5 and now
that the f5 pawn is gone I can access h5
and then Queen h4 me and he actually
played it out like it's been a while
since I've made it someone over the
board so not a bad way to start round
one
let me promote all these variations at
least some mainline Oh make me and mine
that's useful ooh
I think that's one feature that chess
based on
have it's in chess pace if you're like
in a sub variation you have to keep
promoting it
Thank You Lee chess so relatively cook
win I think what I'll do is check some
lines with stock fish I was pretty
involved with the game I thought I I was
seeing most things correctly
we'll check real quick if I overlooked
anything also see where the novelty was
see for Bishop a6 still opening still
has been played before rook c8 yeah
truck c1 probably not a good move
so one game here so night before was a
novelty uh-huh
wait see Fox Queen not trapped bishop f1
rook c1 - I miss that and of course I'm
not playing Queen d3 but bishop f1 rook
c1 queen takes you one okay so the queen
is not trapped but White's winning this
like a bishop yeah wait I'll just double
check with stockfish to repeat to Queens
e3 stockfish bishop battle on winning
yeah bishop f1 plus two okay so let's go
back opening or an I so III I'll just
leave stockfish on Bishop a6
so nothing to nillable yet I was
actually thinking he might play Queenie
- it looks like such an ugly move given
that he puts his rook and/or he has his
rook and his Queen on the same diagonal
as a bishop but I can't easily exploit
that I wasn't entirely sure what to do
here hmm 97 look strange yeah I don't
know what I would have done maybe take
on c4 because if the pawn gets to c4
there's some some positional play for
black oh thank you for the nice message
aka cuttlefish okay let's see what
happened the game uh might be for a 95
97 97 decently strong move take take was
not enough three possible oh nine of
three maybe I can win a pawn I'm take
take or maybe not I was looking at f/16
93 okay hmm can I win c4 like take B
take and then take oh maybe I went too
far
oh he is neither for stockfish too
strong neither for classic computer move
okay Z Fox is asking is your main
advantage you're more active Bishop
should white take on c5 earlier to have
more active Bishop that was definitely
one of the
is going for lack as this bishop on e6
exerts so much pressure and prevents
white from relieving the pond tension in
the center so he's asking could black or
could white take on c5 earlier um maybe
I could take on c5 but it helps activate
I would say probably take back with
bishop but maybe taking on c5 is okay I
take I think what these physicians are
generally equal until until something
concrete happens but yeah the advantage
came later
like I think once the position
transformed like even around here I was
feeling pretty good like knight c6
because blacks pieces are just simply
better like whites bishops not doing too
much and blacks minor pieces just
exerting so much pressure so even in the
sign because black at c4 in it wasn't
really too much for a white to do so I
guess like maybe plus or minus 0.3 ooh
plus 0.1 H for whites h4 is a nice move
ideas of like a king h2 Bishop h3 I saw
this possibility but I didn't really
think it's that great because it's slow
but maybe it makes sense I think I would
play when I play here he plays h4 and I
was looking to play c4 so maybe not c4 b
takes c4
Kru 64 is calling me out I have no idea
what color fish is saying okay I think I
would still be happy here it's kind of a
dynamic pawn structure where black does
have three pawn islands and isolated D
pawn but the D pawn isn't weak and I
have the majority on the Queen side or
the eventual plan is to make a pass be
pawn and I thought 90 to 95 he could get
the bishop here but this Bishop so bad
Bishop c3 makes sense actually hmm
actually Bishop c3 makes a lot of sense
so maybe that's just not better why does
the engine want g 6g 6 is normal but it
was in a previous position does this
position G 6 I think it's just a basic
improving the flagged engine doesn't
know what else to do and white doesn't
necessarily want to go for it like a
king site attack the main point of h4 is
to to try and prepare bishop h3 I think
so
oh he wants to fight me I had a fight
with Cruz 64 a few days ago of some
bullet match and he barely beat me I was
like 15 to 14 but I gained more rating
points so I think it was okay anyway uh
yeah that was an interesting line but he
played rooks he too
I play c4 we take I take yeah so it's
just here after 95 it's probably like at
least - - yeah just fish of taking five
fish I'd be three so pretty bad under
sometimes that happens like first round
people just miss stuff yeah this
position I guess White has options let's
look at the sign mighty 253 rook c3
bishop g6 prefer Bishop f5 Queen on
three Oh Queen f3 might take tea for
nice tactics Queen a1 no one would ever
play it's a very typical stockfish move
maybe it makes sense to get the rook to
see one but just so weird yeah I would
have been happy here okay that was my
game I don't know if it was too
instructive but the opening was
interesting I think this will happen a
lot from these sort of ready
feigning Quetta openings where like
there's so much pawn tension and it's
just a matter of dealing with it putting
your pieces on good squares so this has
been a very quick stream I'm gonna end
it there thanks guys for watching and I
might do more of these but I might not
so we'll see
have a good night's and bye